jessica's with us in dallas hi Jessica
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hire oh
my god what an honor to talk to you hey
I have a couple of questions it's my
birthday next week record actually
trying to get to come and see you in
Dallas here but a question I do have is
my husband is a finance manager at a
dealership and he so his salary is very
inconsistent and I'm a stay-at-home mom
here and we're in kind of a mess as far
as with two credit cards and some
medical bills from our miscarriage last
year and so we haven't his income hasn't
been very high as far as even being able
to cover our needs and so we haven't
been able to put any money towards any
of the debt and our highest credit card
minimum payment is like a thousand
dollars I'm trying to figure out do we
pay medical and I know you want us to do
Louis you know smallest the highest but
I want you to be current first okay
first goals but yeah but I first golden
dollars no so your problem is not the
thousand dollars your problem is income
right the thousand being short of income
is what's causing all of this so what's
he making what kind of income I don't
even know I don't even know it's a fine
offender it usually makes a good amount
of money it's just been slow going so
I'm not really sure he made about 90
last year 19 to do 90 thousand last year
if he was a car salesman last year so he
did Oh motion he got a promotion makes
less money yeah but I thought he'd be
making more money as a finance manager
and trying to figure out what the deal
is
yeah I want to know what this cheque
says and you don't know what his cheque
says no danger danger you need to know
what check says they have them unlike a
junior pay pine until he can you know
prove himself so that you need to know
what his cheque says you don't know and
that's part of where your freak-outs
coming from so it's not it's not wrong
you know every detail of every piece of
income that's coming into your house
regardless of where it's coming from
that would be a normal marriage and so a
properly run high communication marriage
so you need to sit down with him and you
need to understand exactly what he is
making he needs to understand exactly
what he's making and what the crack is
for him to get back above 90 because 90
doesn't sound like somebody's got
problem $1,000 payments right right
exactly yeah so you you guys got to get
on top of this you're worrying about a
lot of stuff that you don't know what's
going on and that's increasing you're
worried not knowing is what's killing
you as much as anything this is the Dave
Ramsey show
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below
you